live to New York where world leaders
have gathered for the United Nations
General Assembly they are expected to
discuss a number of issues including the
war in Ukraine and climate change U.N
Chief Antonio Gutierrez is speaking at
the moment we're going to go uh live to
James Bays now our diplomatic editor who
has been listening and what has uh the
Secretary General been talking about so
far in his opening address
yeah
yeah he's painting a very Grim picture
of the state of the world he started
with the situation in derna in Libya
saying the people there were victims of
conflict victims of climate chaos and
victims of world leaders who are not
doing enough
um he says the world is in a mess with
regard to conflict within regard to
poverty and inequality and yet the world
is not coming together there's a
fracturing of world leaders gathering in
different blocks and he says the basic
structures of international governance
the U.N security Council the financial
organizations like the IMF and the World
Bank are no longer fit for purpose they
are outdated institutions that were
built for a world at the end of World
War II not for a world as it is now
let's listen now to a little bit more of
the Secretary General as he continues
his speech
excellencies
the peace and security architecture is
under unprecedented strain
that is why in the context of the
preparations for the summit of the
future
we put forward ideas for the
consideration of member states for a new
agenda for peace based on the charter
and international law
it provides a unifying Vision to address
existing and new threats for a world in
transition
calling on states to recommit to all
three from nuclear weapons and to end
the erosion of the nuclear disarmament
and arms control regime
boasting prevention at the global level
by maximizing the capacity and convening
power of the UN and our good offices to
bridge geopolitical divides
boasting prevention at the national
level by linking actions for peace with
progress on the sustainable development
goals
putting women's leadership and
participation at the center of decision
making
and committing to the dedication of all
forms of violence against women
calling for a broad-based reflection on
peacekeeping and make it nimbled and
more adaptable with forward-looking
transition and exit strategies from the
start
and supporting peace enforcement peace
enforcement action by Regional
organizations notably the African Union
with Security Council clear mandates and
predictable fundings
determination for peace also requires
new governance Frameworks for emerging
threats
from artificial intelligence to little
autonomous weapons lithium autonomous
weapons that function without human
control
excellencies
peace is inextricably linked to
sustainable developments
we see a familiar pattern around the
world the closer a countries to conflict
the further is far from the sustainable
development goals
the charter calls on us to be determined
in promoting social progress
in 21st century terms that means
achieving the sustainable development
goals
yet inequality defines our time
from cities where skyscrapers Tower over
slums
to countries that are forced to choose
between serving their people or serving
their debts
today Africa spends more on that
interest than on elsecares
yesterday's sdg Summit was about a
global rescue plan to scale up support
from billions to trillions
and excellencies the International
Financial architecture remains
dysfunctional outdated and unjust
and they did reform that I needed won't
happen overnight but we can take
determined steps now to help countries
where the crisis such as the profit 19
pandemic have dramatically impacted
by urgently advancing the STD stimulus
of 500 billion dollars per year and
relieving the financial burden on
developing and emerging economies
by scaling up development and climate
Finance increasing the capital base and
changing the business model of
multilateral development Banks by
ensuring effective debt relief
mechanisms and channeling emergency
financial support towards those in
greatest needs
excellencies
we must be determined to tackle the most
immediate threat to our future
our overheating planets
climate change is not just a change in
the weather
climate change is changing life on our
planet
it is affecting every aspect of our work
it is killing people and devastating
communities
around the world we see not only
accelerating temperatures we see an
acceleration in sea levels Rising
glaciers receding deadly disease is
spreading the extinction of species and
cities and the threats
and this is only the beginnings
we have just survived the hottest days
the hottest months and the hottest
summer on the books
behind every broken records are broken
economies broken lives and All Nations
at the breaking point
every continent every region and every
country is feeling the Heat
but I'm not sure all leaders are feeling
that hits
actions are failing abysmally short
there is still time to keep Rising
temperatures within the 1.5 degree
limits of the Paris agreements
but that requires drastic steps now to
cut green greenhouse gas emissions and
to ensure climate Justice for those who
did least to cause the crisis that are
paying the highest price
we have three seats
20 countries are responsible for 80
percent of greenhouse emissions they
must lead
they must break their addiction to
fossil fuels stop new coal indeed the
International Energy agency's findings
that new oil and gas licensing by them
is incompatible with keeping the 1.5
degree limits alive
to stand the Fighting Chance of limiting
Global temperature rise we must phase
out whole oil and gas in a fair and
Equitable way and massively boost
Renewables
this is the only pass to Affordable
renewable energy for all and
unfortunately many still in Africa
mainly in Africa still lack electricity
so the fossil full age has failed
a fossil full companies want to be part
of the solution they must lead the
transition to renewable energy
no more dirty production no more fake
Solutions no more bankrolling climate
denial
I have laid out the climate solidarity
pacts in which all big emitters are
asked to make extra efforts to cut
emissions and welshier countries support
emerging economies with finance and
Technology to do so
for example Africa 60 percent of the
world's solar capacity but just two
percent of renewable Investments
and I've also put forward an
acceleration agenda to supercharge these
efforts
developed countries must reach Net Zero
as close as possible to 2040 and the
emerging economies as close as possible
to 2050 in line with common but
differentiated responsibilities
and the immediate steps include an end
to call by 2030 for oecd countries and
2040 for the rest of the world
and then to fossil fuel subsidies and
the price on carbon
developed countries must also finally
delivered 100 billion US dollars for
developing country climate action as
promised double adaptation Finance by
2025 as promised and replenish the green
climate fund as promised
and all countries must work to
operationalize the loss and damage fund
this year and ensure Universal early
warning coverage by 2027.
tomorrow I will welcome credible first
movers and doers to our climate ambition
summits
and cop 28 is around the corner
climate chaos is breaking new records
but we cannot afford the same old broken
record of scapegoating and waiting for
others to move first
and to all those working marching and
championing real climate action I want
you to know that you are on the right
side of history and that I am with you
I won't give up this fight of Our Lives
excellence
foreign